Mayor's office.
Hi, I'm Jessica Perez, I'm
meeting with Mayor Wilson, and she said she
was sending a car over to pick me up at the airport.
Can I please see you on a brief hold while I
check on this?
Yes. Of course.
Excuse me.
Oh, I am so sorry.
I didn't mean to hit it. I- it got stuck.
Please. All yours. Just steer clear of 'D'.
Actually I was-
Yes, I'm here. Yes.
Thank you. Right.
Thank you for your patience.
I just spoke with the mayor and your ride
should be there.
At Tapeesa Airport?
Yes.
Well, I don't know what to tell you because I'm
standing in the
middle of the only hangar in existence, and
there is no one else here- Oh... you know,
thank you for your help. I think I found him.
Are you my ride?
Matt Holden.
My family grows the jingle bell flowers for
the festival.
Mayor Wilson asked me to make
sure that you had everything that you needed.
Yes. Good. Thank you. I'm so sorry about
before, I. I guess I was just expecting
someone, you know, with a sign.
A sign?
With my name on it? So, they can find me
at the gate.
Right. Wouldn't want to miss you with all
these people here.
Right.
Are those my cookies?
Oh, yeah, I mean, I did spring them free. We
can share.
Oh, no, I don't think so.
Okay, well, my truck is parked outside.
Oh, wait.
Truck?